so
forespoken came out and I did not love
the trailer for this game I have a
separate video about that um but I
missed kind of how full spoken performed
after launch one thing here um before we
get to the fact that the entire Studio
shut down
[Laughter]
first things
is an article from vg247 from February
15th house will spoken well you can
already get it for under 30 pounds
what why did you choose this screenshot
what is this
uh roughly three weeks since launch
while spoken is already on sale for less
than 30 pounds at an online retailer
cool shop you can even get free shipping
this followed mixed reviews which I
guess we can also open that were largely
torn between beautiful Aesthetics but a
lackluster narrative in addition there
was intense online criticism levied at
the game's in-game dialogue which many
believed painted the game in an awkward
light and I do have some opinions on
that about the awkward dialogue which is
certainly was the issue with the trailer
and that was just exemplified by being
portrayed as awkward because the way
that it was cut and it was weird in the
demo too because we didn't have a lot of
context for who she was or why she was
saying these things there are a lot of
things that I think I think that this
protagonist says that wouldn't be any
different to things that the characters
say in Final Fantasy 15. it's the
context of them that makes it feel weird
she even says some things that wouldn't
be that dissimilar to a Nathan Drake
like
some of the interaction with
uh enemies is not that dissimilar to a
million video game protagonists that
we've had before the difference is very
much in the context and I think the
context of that is the isakai which is a
pretty common genre in anime which is
basically just a character is picked up
and put into a world they don't
understand usually somebody in an
essekay is on the back foot they're like
what is this what's this world what's
Happening Here whereas Frey is like I'm
from Hell's Kitchen she should have the
intelligence to know that nobody in this
world that she's never seen
should know what Hell's Kitchen is and
so the Fish Out of Water Trope right
doesn't work because at no point does
she acknowledge that she's a fish out of
water she talks to everybody including
the cuff as though she's still in New
York despite making occasional comments
about like what is this place she's just
talking to people in a way that nobody
would ever talk to people in The Fish
Out of Water context it's very very very
strange yeah it was just contextually
lack of self-awareness I agree
and the volume of talking also an issue
was just really odd and it's also odd
for you as the player character to have
that disconnect with your protagonist
where you think she should be saying
where are we what are we doing and she's
like ah I'm from Kell's kitchen don't
you know about this reference to the
modern world that of course you don't
know and so you you're like why are you
saying this lady I know they don't know
that how do you not know they know that
and you never want to feel that much
smarter than your protagonist I have
that much info over your protagonist
just really really really strange the
thing that I disliked about the pacing
of the story the most actually having
not finished the doodle and the thing
that I found the most frustrating and I
consistently do find really frustrating
was actually the amount of cutscenes or
the amount of times that the game took
control away from the player um it ended
up really grating on me there was just
so much story that set up very little
that I actually cared about
um that you either had to walk really
slowly or it just froze every few
seconds
um and I really advocate for games not
doing that like especially if you have
cool gameplay which I actually think
full spoken does if you watch people who
are later in the game who have a better
understanding of the combat play around
with it it actually looks really neat
once you kind of get um your preferences
down and you get a grasp with how it
works it looks really cool
um Okay so
it appears as though the sentiment is
widely held by the general gaming
audience which is that it was a mixed
reviews as the game sold worse on PC
than Hi-Fi Rush
I did not know that Hi-Fi rush out form
outperform spoken on Steam a game that
had no marketing oh my gosh the surprise
Microsoft game reportedly made more
Revenue than Square enix's title that is
nuts according to the same weekly Global
top sellers list on Steam DB which lists
the best-selling games on Steam by
Revenue made Hi-Fi Rush came in at
number eight and well spoken didn't make
the top ten that is wild I love Hi-Fi
Rush by the way I think Hi-Fi Rush is
fantastic you have to play it if you
haven't played it I would recommend it
to literally everybody which applies to
so few games and related to that I don't
think that everybody would hate full
spoken
um I just think that the the lack of
context is objectionable to most humans
because of the disconnect between the
player character and the player like
there's just a massive disconnect
between what she's saying and what we're
feeling at any given time that it's
consistently off-putting and it's always
going to be that way it's almost written
like it is an anime
or like it's a TV show script where you
have to buy into how they're feeling or
who that character is and it doesn't
work when you're playing as their
character it's just ah
um the difference is particularly
notable and forespoken has been
supported with sizable marketing
campaign whereas Hi-Fi Rush appeared
without any warning or prior reveal as
part of last week's Xbox developer
direct presentation
damn
that's the second article so this is the
one about
forespoken
beaten by dead space in January well
spoken sales don't appear to be off to a
red start the game is already being
outpaced by dead space or remake at
retail and Hi-Fi Rush on Steam both of
them at once man now Sony has revealed
that it didn't do really well in 2023's
PS4 download shots either for spoken
sales outpaced by all the games but then
just four days on the market Dead Space
was the second most downloaded PS4 game
in the US and sorry PS5 game in the US
and Canada and the fourth most
downloaded game in the UK and Europe for
spoken which released three days prior
to Dead Space debuted at number seven in
the US and Canada and number five in the
UK slash Europe it's unusual for a PS5
console to debut Solo in the charts
that's exactly what I was thinking it's
unusual for a PS5 console exclusive to
debut so low in the charts it's pretty
uncommon and be beaten to the Top by all
the games in January the Unstoppable
Grand Theft Auto 5. who doesn't own
Grand Theft Auto 5
sales records I'm like who are these
people who don't already own Grand Theft
Auto 5 and I'm like oh it's children
literally what's keeping the GTA 5
Market afloat
is that more people are born every year
who just exist to buy GTA 5. thanks in
part to the success of the HBO show
philosophers part one re-entered the top
10 in both U.S Canada and UK Europe
which is interesting because I figured
that's why they made The Last of Us Part
One I bought it I'm happily replaying it
but that is a pretty old game uh
wherefore spoken did have a lot of
marketing it was like we all knew what
it was or at least most of us seem to
have like it it was successfully
marketed just not favorably marketed so
forespoken was beaten by dead space and
HiFi rush and The Last of Us Part One
which is not a great sign
um and did have middling reviews I
haven't read any of the reviews so let's
just actually like pull up the
Metacritic
oh I did not know that I didn't know
that happened to it
I knew that I didn't like it
um I knew that they didn't give out
review codes to a lot of people I also
did not get one
I didn't know I got a 64. for a like a
triple a square Unix game dang let's
read the 95 from gaming Nexus
um okay
I knew Square Enix back when it was just
Square oh this is terrible no sorry
gaming Nexus this is like one of my
biggest pet peeves as somebody who has
edited a lot of video game journalists
please don't tell me your life story
ever as part of the review I knew Square
Enix back when it was just Square even
Square soft
they're responsible for my introduction
into role-playing games like Final
Fantasy and Chrono Trigger and secretive
Mana from an early age I was nobody
cares to talk about this bucket oh you
can just really delete all of this
um allow any preface this review with
some insights from my own recent gaming
experience I will not no I'm not gonna
do that
you take the role of Frey and often 21
year old who is unwillingly involved in
the wrong crowd in New York City she
lives alone in a one-bedroom apartment
with her cat Homer and her kicks
she's like the only thing she looked
forward to
oh gosh uh done with court dates running
around doing petty crime and answering
to a boss who takes a cut of a pie Frey
finds herself trying to collect enough
money to buy the first plane ticket out
of NYC and a plan literally goes up and
smoke when her apartment with stash
money goes up in Flames I did see all of
that yes
okay the setup is all the story you get
for this sorry not sorry that's so much
setup dude
you don't need to apologize you're fine
okay Athea is absolutely stunning even
though most food is run by the break the
landscape is amazing you can see pretty
much everything this is a really bad
review
it's okay no hey I gotta get through it
okay it's fine
it's okay I'm being an [__]
I'm glad that you uh writing your
opinions on video games and I encourage
that
um
I didn't notice any draw distance
meaning no matter what I saw in the
distance it just didn't pop out of
nowhere
okay
any place I saw I could go there was a
Mountainside to scale I could do most of
it in the early stages of freeze Journey
Blades of grass and full trees blue or
even sometimes Red Skies enemies flying
or walking around in the distance
waiting on you to approach them they're
all seen here beautifully there is no
guesswork whatever the wizard luminous
did to make this world and cities look
the way they do ravaged or not is a work
of art that should be praised you have
to see it for yourself but forespoken is
indeed
a beautiful game they think the world
looks good with that said you could even
make the game more beautiful within
depending on your settings preferences
can't I don't I can't
I feel really bad this makes me feel
really bad I don't feel good doing this
publicly
stop
just don't
no okay here this is the positive one
we're gonna get through all right
we got it okay
to infinite.net for spoken review
exceptional gameplay cuffed to a rough
stop seriously though let's get all of
this straight
a few games could hope to make a worse
first impression than full spoken
this is the positive review
but I will let you finish happy with
corny dialogue and host to a series of
lines that made the internet meme
circuit prior to its launch the game was
Infamous well before people even had a
chance to get their hands on it but
while notice full of life as some might
have hoped definitely agreed on that it
felt empty as hell to me it's still a
sizable sandbox for players to get lost
in there are a wide variety of biomes
and regions that feel distinct from one
another and provide a healthy amount of
side content for players to get
distracted by the music and sound design
improve the title's overall experience
just as much I actually did think that
the sound design was very good um
ranging from softer catchier beats to
booming orchestral Arrangements mixed
with chanting choirs the soundtrack is a
perfect accompaniment to the snarling of
corrupted animals and humans and then
there's the gameplay to say this is the
main selling point of spoken would be a
massive understatement as it provides
some of the best open World gameplay
mechanics one could hope to find wow
I also thought the Spells were very good
looking legendary loot for the soul I
didn't think they were that boring
outside of like the shooty one I liked
the sword thing a lot
um and the game looks even cooler when
you like I said earlier
when you see someone who's really late
game who've like actually leveled up
their tree it looks awesome I just
couldn't get through
all of the stuff to get there was my
problem they lost the pros as traversal
and Combat gameplay stunning Graphics
solid music and voice acting I I guess
it's visually impressive but I wouldn't
say stunning Graphics because it's Bleak
like the world is not that enjoyable you
know
very cringy writing other cons uh
painfully slow and Exposition heavy
introduction yep open world feels a bit
lifeless okay they mentioned it so
it's all of that leading to for spoken
Studio luminous Productions has been
shut down its developers have been
folded into Square Enix publisher Square
Enix has just confirmed by a short press
release that its subsidiary Studio
luminous Productions will be shutting
down its developers will be folded into
the largest Square Enix development arm
again this game did review very poorly I
didn't like it it clearly didn't sell
very well but this is also amidst this
like Square going through this huge
merger and fully changing the way that
they're they're treating their teams um
and effectively a buyout so it's
kind of hard to to say necessarily
latest Productions officially released
only one title the critically mixed open
world RPG forespoken which came out
about a month ago so it appears far from
coincidental that Square Enix is now
deciding to shut the studio down though
forespoken wasn't a commercial flop
just kind of a critical flop
though not the success it feels like it
should have been I don't know ranking
seventh in the list of best-selling
games in the United States of January
2023 as per NPD Square still clearly
considered that luminous devs were
better off working on other projects
rather than making their own as per
official statement by luminous as saying
below let's just read this then an
update from luminous Productions you may
have heard the news and luminous
Productions is merging with square
Innings beginning on May 1st our
talented team will join Square Enix to
deliver new Innovative gaming
experiences to players across the globe
between now and then we remain entirely
focused on forespoken we are currently
working on the previously announced
patch to address overall game
performance we will deliver an update
soon and the DLC in Tonto We Trust is on
track for release this summer thank you
again for your patience and support
when we establish luminous Productions
in 2018 our vision was to make AAA games
the fuse technology and Artistry to
deliver completely new play experiences
having the chance to do that has been a
dream come true we appreciate you taking
this journey with us and look forward to
continuing to create new entertainment
and experiences as part of the squarings
family luminous Productions was
officially established in 2018 which is
why for spoken was their first known the
game however the team ended up becoming
that ended up becoming luminous was the
same one that developed Final Fantasy XV
as we've mentioned I titled that though
much better it's even full spoken did
suffer through a lot of Developmental
turmoil that is a very good point I had
forgotten about that it was a mess
according to Square Enix the reason
behind the merger comes from the
company's efforts to further bolster the
competitive priority Square development
Studios a goals set forth under its
current medium-term business strategy
yeah
the press release Praises luminous
production stating the team is equipped
not only with AAA title development
capabilities but also technical
expertise in areas such as game engine
development it finalizes by stating that
combining the two entities will further
enhance the group's ability to develop
HD games and then
we have that original story
which is just there's a lot of
interesting stuff going on for square
right now so they folded a studio
basically to fold the devs into square
proper they've sold off a lot of their
Western IP they had a run-in with nfts
that I think they then walked back I'm
just not entirely sure what square is up
to right now they're in a strange place
um obviously they're doing a great job
with Final Fantasy 14.
I don't know it's interesting so this
news came earlier this week which is
Square Enix president yosuke matsuda to
be replaced amid a rapidly changing
business environment yusuke matsuda is
getting ready to step down as the
president of Square Enix this marks the
end of his 10-year run at the Helm of
the Japanese game publisher Square Enix
announced the changes in a statement to
investors saying that matsuda would have
stepped down as president later this
year the proposal must be first approved
at the annual shareholders meeting in
June the company didn't specify the
exact reason behind this decision but
noted that it was dictated by the rapid
change of business environments
surrounding the entertainment industry
whoever steps up
will give you an idea of what Square's
business goals are right now is it live
service that's what I always worry about
this is in line with squaring it's a
strategy to reshape the management team
with the goal of adopting ever-evolving
technological innovations sounds like
live service games
and maximizing on the creativity of the
company's group in order to deliver even
greater entertainment to its customers
around the world oh there we go we have
the ex the replacement
matsuda will be replaced by another
executive Takashi kiriu who joined the
Japanese publisher in 2020 and worked
across several positions such as Chief
strategy officer and director of the
entire holding I'm going to look up his
business background
started screenings in October 2001 and
took over from previous president
yoichiware in 2013 under his leadership
the company shipped dozens of games and
went through some turbulent times in
2021 he was also among the highest paid
gaming Executives with annual earnings
of 4.1 million to Square Enix my God uh
one of the latest moves from matsuda as
president of Square Enix was the sale of
the company's Western Studios yeah which
is still wild I'm so interested to see
how that shapes out it could be really
positive it could be terrible in May
2022 Embrace a group of quiet edos
Montreal sorry idos Montreal Crystal
Dynamics and now closed Square Enix
Montreal for around 300 million
so I would like to learn a little bit
more about Takashi Kiryu and what
this gentleman wants from business
and why this looks like AI
oh this is where he came from
densu Japan
metabus production a joint project aimed
at reducing greenhouse gases and
improving process efficiency in video
game Sorry video production workflows
interesting so it's metaverse 3D
production is where he came from be
interesting
to see
um
we'll see how it goes but yeah I think
uh it's always a bummer when a studio
closes in this case it seems like they
would just kind of folded into
Square so it seems like that whole Dev
team is okay
um I feel like for spoken was just like
a very misguided effort and it makes
sense to me how it turned out the way
that it did when the marketing was so
off-putting initially I think that what
I would have done if I you know were in
any position and not just talking out of
my ass would be delay it and change it
um find the position sorry when the
outcry is that strong or at least do
more play testing because surely they
would have gotten some negative stuff
there
surely they would have like had a bunch
of criticisms yeah right and the demo
was so negative right like you could
have done a Sonic and been like ah let's
delete that a little bit
let's just push that back a tiny bit
I don't know seems like a
a real shame